what's more painful battling on-screen
and constrained outfits it looks amazing
it feels terrible or getting into the
costumes and prosthetics themselves i
mean it's just a feeling of like
claustrophobia we've got 20 of the most
elaborate costumes and prosthetics that
were a total nightmare to work with
coming at you i think it's going to be a
really fun surprise for the audience
number one it's a look and ever since
the reveal of the new scarlet witch at
the end of wandavision we've grown to
love this fierce character even more and
olsen is way more into wearing this
version when the actress first joined
the mcu for civil war she wasn't so into
the constricting and totally impractical
costume that was her corset that was the
worst thing is i did wear
it was uncomfortable to battle in but
what really put the actress off was the
fact that it was so revealing that's
awful yeah that's a terrible feeling
when it was time to bring the new design
to the mcu olson was consulted to make
sure that the outfit would work and make
her feel like the superhero that she
very clearly is
number two get a load of that cloak
it's one thing to wear a heavy costume
or to carry around large outfits but
cumberbatch was backed into a corner
since he was in a harness and screwed
into place very tightly this was to
ensure his safety while filming but that
didn't mean the actor was a fan of the
situation
as the cloak was coming on i just sort
of looked in the mirror and i started to
smile like a giddy child he shared a
struggle a few other superheroes have
explaining what was difficult was going
for a bathroom break you have to get out
of it all and put it back on again it
was just arduous for everyone ardrew is
for everyone yes but mostly benedict
that that's quite often happens number
three
do the layers ever end chiwetel ejiofor
wears just as many layers in doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness as
he did in the first doctor strange film
an unfortunate reality for the actor
layers on layers on layers well they can
only lead to one thing an extremely
overheated actor it was a full
experience it was like nothing else
really number four
he just wants a zip what's funny is that
during no way home holland discovered
another spidey did in fact have zips
andrew garfield's costume had small ones
that allowed him to use his hands
meanwhile poor tom was still using his
nose trying to work his cell phone one
thing that all the spider-man struggled
with because i wear the suit i can't go
to the bathroom garfield said we were
like oh my god like you find it hard to
pee in the suit i find it hard to pee in
the suit oh yeah and then there's the
whole drinking with the mask on issue
cue a straw going through an eye socket
and on top of all of that holland was
getting all sorts of cuts and bruises
around his wrists because of the gold
gauntlets that he had to wear that's why
when i shoot webs in the suit i i don't
do this i do this
the spidey struggle is real those stupid
gauntlets number five stepping into the
role was tougher than he'd anticipated
there were big and painful shoes to fill
for wyatt russell when he stepped in as
captain america to begin according to
russell the cap suit was hot
very difficult it was oh god
take it off
the suit became a risk for the actor to
wear on set as well since it was such an
uncomfortable costume that it
re-aggravated an old injury from the
actors hockey days russell's hands were
tied and as a result he shared that my
shoulders kind of got screwed up and
things started to hurt just because of
the position that the suit would put you
in all day and considering how many days
they spent shooting yeah it sounds like
this cap was definitely hurting by the
end of filming number six
this is a thor we never thought we'd see
it was the hottest i've ever been
chris hemsworth is strong there's no
doubt about it but disguising himself as
the out-of-shape version of thor wound
up requiring even more strength since
the fat suit he wore added about 60 to
70 pounds of weight to carry around then
there was the hair beard and makeup
portion needing to puff his cheeks out
of it resulted in a bit of a vocal
change as well but in the end it worked
shockingly well to bring this character
to life
number seven any guesses which costume
aspect was the heaviest i was terrified
of the suit
salma hayek's first time in the mcu was
brutal and she got to know just how hard
superhero costumes could be to work in i
started on sipping myself in the middle
of a movie because i just need to
breathe so hayek wasn't feeling nearly
as fly as she was looking her headgear
wound up being straight up dangerous but
for selma the goal was clear
unfortunately the actress did suffer
brutal neck strain because of her wig
and the headpiece
number 8 it was agatha all along as
incredible as she looked flying in the
sky underneath those dark and witchy
looking layers were some very necessary
tools for context one division was
filmed in la where there were some
serious california fires happening at
the time which made the already hot
state a brutal place to work catherine
hahn was grateful for her secret weapon
explaining there was no way i could have
done it without it it was imperative
beneath her costume was a cooling suit
the actress didn't want to deal with
another layer but it wound up being a
blessing between takes my amazing
costume assistant beth would squeeze
coils of cold water underneath my
costume teamwork makes the dream work
also cooling suits
like a hundred and something degrees and
it was a whole team that built her
number nine did we expect the suit to be
comfortable just looking at it it's not
too surprising that the suit caused the
black widow actress a whole lot of grief
as johansson put it it was so hot i
would wring out my socks at the end of
the day yeah this avenger was sweating
buckets in what was essentially a
wetsuit unfortunately johansen had a
frighteningly close call when she began
to hallucinate during a big fight scene
because she was so overheated number 10
layers are cool but it really depends on
where you are filming in the canary
islands sounds like a bit of a dream but
for the druid actor there were some
seriously rough downsides for the fourth
time which was weird maybe if his
costume hadn't been so heavy it would
have been easier but the reality was as
barry put it there were three layers to
it and i complained every day about it
especially as we were filming in the
heat the actor originally from ireland
was not thriving in this extra hot
climate sweating endlessly and
struggling to work through the nausea
number 11. now this one was a doozy
joyman hunzo didn't have it easy when it
came to the transformation into his
character the actor was honest about his
experience saying it was five hours of
makeup on a daily basis and then the
wardrobe was uncomfortable and the worst
part is the costume could cause him even
more harm because if he moved the wrong
way he would accidentally wind up
cutting himself number 12 out of this
world looks take some time to perfect
karen gillan sports the nebula look like
a boss and during filming of guardians
of the galaxy 3 she celebrated having
her nebula makeup and prosthetics put on
for the
170th time gillen is the first to admit
that the look itself is pretty intense
calling it creepy and weirdly doll-like
childlike almost oh and in order to gear
up in all those prosthetic pieces the
actress needed to shave off her hair at
the end of the workday gillen was again
reminded of just how irritating her
makeup and prosthetics were spending a
long period in the makeup chair escaping
the clothes of her character if you can
take risks and that's when the
interesting stuff happens number 13. is
there an actor under all that prosthetic
you bet there is and ben mendelsohn has
survived to tell the tale of his
claustrophobic and intensely
uncomfortable mcu costume the ratio of
time spent in the makeup chair versus on
the set was pretty wacky but it did
enable him to embody the character
completely even if it did cause the
actor some harm he came he swept he got
lightheaded his skin suffered but in the
end he conquered
number 14. how many prosthetics can you
fit on one face
dave bautista might hold the record for
the amount of special facial prosthetics
that had to be applied to become his mcu
character drax the third guardians movie
saw bautista once more injuring all the
heavy layers of makeup for endless hours
the removal process is almost worst
torture than actually wearing it what
did bautista have to say about it it's
almost as long to take it off it's like
glue it's so abrasive so they take it
off slowly number 15
he's always a vision paul bettany has
gotten used to three and a half hour
prosthetic application sessions but it
doesn't mean he likes them at all when
it was time for the black and white
vision and wandavision he was looking
far more blue than we'd ever seen him
from a tight headpiece that doesn't
allow him to hear to full makeup and
prosthetic application only for
everything to be redone with cgi anyway
petny really couldn't catch a break yes
no yes no
i don't know am i
number 16
another overheated actor coming up a
black cat suit in 90 degree weather it
doesn't sound comfortable and chadwick
boseman confirmed it is not he often
felt like his oxygen supply was
essentially cut off when he was sealed
into that suit the fact that he couldn't
even scratch itches he was getting
because of the sweat trickling down his
body was just an added layer of torture
number 17
no surprise there were prosthetics
involved on this one chris sullivan went
through the rite of passage so many mcu
actors do living through hours of
painful prosthetics application and
while it was a nightmare each time we
can't ignore how realistic and
incredible he looks on screen
number 18 was he going for the record of
amount of prosthetics worn all those
marks on his body the ones for every
life he'd taken the vicious scars were
in fact individually applied prosthetics
over 3 000 pieces were applied every day
the team in jordan learned very quickly
that filming fights in water with a ton
of painstakingly applied prosthetics
makes for a bit of a nightmare across
the board nah
i'm your kid
number 19. five hours in a makeup chair
no big deal zoe saldana is a pro at
getting her makeup put on to become
gamora she has spent hours doing it
after all she's also got a prosthetic
forehead and cheekbones which let's face
it are never really comfortable as for
the feeling of green makeup covering
most of the upper half of her body it
was almost as rough to deal with as the
prosthetic removal process sometimes
we'd be a little over worked and a
little tired number 20. now this just
sounds like an uncomfortable suit and
you can bet it was while over the years
there have been many changes to make the
famous suit a bit more bearable robert
downey jr got his fair share of
overheated moments aches pains and
lasting bruises
all in a day's work as an avenger
the fact is superhero costumes usually
lean more towards style than comfort
though we don't think these performers
would mind some slight improvements here
and there which characters prosthetics
do you think would have been toughest to
get applied